it could lead to one of the biggest
agricultural disasters in Europe zile
Elif Asti do sir the killer bacteria
imported most likely from Latin America
via Rotterdam in the Netherlands it's
already infected up to 1 million olive
trees in the south of Italy Sicilian MEP
Giovanni la vía is in favor of
eradicating trees in certain buffer
zones when you reset Kappa Kappa Sonia
Tovar a day Renee D to be my search
chair Takeda batygin on single investor
ultra special vegetal epilobium
Privitera piano repair they succeed they
ring boss that he psycho straight to a
steel Paralympian take more money for
research and compensation for olive tree
growers a position shared by the
majority of mep is in plenary on
wednesday some also support the use of
pesticides but for the greens this is a
no-go area reports it as usual de quoi
combat proved well a radical is a
secular Victor Pascal is Insecta vectors
on the pugio variety see take on
detecting failure on cupola Basha UO
Pompeii shake because as develop or
personal apology while a definitive
solution to the problem hasn't yet been
found any peace have called on member
states to increase the number of site
inspections